-We're about to do
something fun,
but I'm going to need some help.
So joining me now
is the star of "The J Team,"
which is out now
on Paramount Plus,
the one and only JoJo Siwa!
Yeah!
-Yeah!
How you doing?
-Oh, I love you, buddy.
-Oh!
-JoJo!
-J Team! "The J Team."
That's what I'm talking about.
-Yeah!
-Thank you so much
for being here.
JoJo, whenever
you're on the show,
I like to challenge you
in the form of dance.
And we've done a dance battle --
We've done an aggressive
dance battle.
But this time, I think
the question on everyone's mind
is -- is who's
the faster dancer?
-I'm -- I'm getting old
to do this.
-No, you are -- Please,
you're talking to Grandpa here.
-Going to break a bone
this time.
-Let's find out. It's time for
a "Tonight Show Fast Dance-Off."
-♪ "Tonight Show" dance,
"Tonight Show" fast dance-off ♪
♪ "Tonight Show" fast dance,
dance, dance, dance-off ♪
-Oxygen tank's on standby,
right?
-Here we go, come on.
We're going to take turns
dancing as fast as we can.
But to make things fun, we will
not be dancing to fast songs.
[ Laughter ]
We'll be dancing to the slowest,
least danceable songs
we could think of.
JoJo, since you're my guest,
why don't you go first?
Hit the Fast Dance Generator
button whenever you are ready.
-I've been waiting for this one!
-[ Beeping ]
-Always wanted
to press that button.
-Okay.
-Oh!
Got a little Olivia.
-Olivia Rodrigo, okay.
-Alright, I like it.
-Alright, well, go for it.
Whenever you're ready,
hit the floor, man.
Let's see what you got.
-Oh, this is scary.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ And I know
we weren't perfect ♪
♪ But I've never felt this way
for no one ♪
♪ Oh, and I just can't imagine ♪
♪ How you could be so okay
now that I'm gone ♪
♪ I guess you didn't mean ♪
♪ What you wrote in that song
about me ♪
♪ 'Cause you said forever, now I
drive alone past your street ♪
-Oh! Come on, now.
That's --
That's -- That is
a professional.
-I lost so many things
out of my hair.
-Yeah, you had --
Yeah, this barrette came out.
That is a professional
right there.
I don't even know why I would
even try to beat that, but --
Amazing. JoJo Siwa.
Come on, that's --
-Thank you.
-Alright.
Now it is my turn.
-Oh.
-Let's see what I get here.
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter, cheering ]
"Someone You Loved." Okay, yeah.
-Have a blast with that one.
-Yeah. Wait, but that's --
What's "Someone You Loved"?
Oh, Lewis Capaldi.
[ Singing indistinctly ]
-[ Singing indistinctly ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get it.
-♪ I guess I kind of like the
way you numbed all the pain ♪
♪ Now the day bleeds
into nightfall ♪
♪ And you're not here
to get me through it all ♪
♪ I let my guard down ♪
-Oh.
-♪ And then you pulled the rug ♪
♪ I was getting kind of used
to being someone you loved ♪
♪♪
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What in the land of --
just happened?
-I'm hurting in all
weird places right now.
-It's alright. It's alright.
-JoJo, it is your turn again.
-Oh.
-Go for it.
Whew.
I need a water.
[ Beeping ]
So nice.
-Oh.
-Good luck.
-Drama. I actually had a solo
to this song when I was little.
-Oh, really?
-It wasn't fast, though.
-No advantage.
-It was slow.
-Alright.
♪♪
-♪ Say something,
I'm giving up on you ♪
♪♪
♪ And anywhere,
I would have followed you ♪
♪ Oh ♪
-Oh, come on!
Hey! Come on.
-♪ Say something ♪
-That's not fair.
-♪ I'm giving up on you ♪
Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The worm! Come on.
-I haven't done that thing
in a year!
-That was fantastic. The worm!
-My God. I've been training
for "Dancing with the Stars,"
and now I do the worm.
-You got to save that
for "Dancing with the Stars."
-JoJo, you're clearly
the better fast dancer.
-No.
-But let's try one song
maybe together.
Sound good?
-Delightful.
-Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter ]
-This is good. This is good.
-You know, this is a good one.
It's Julia Michaels, JP Saxe.
♪ If the world was ending,
you'd come over, right? ♪
-♪ You'd come over
and you'd stay the night ♪
-Ready?
-No.
-Whew, I know. Me, neither.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good game. Good game.
-Good game.
♪♪
-♪ But if the world was ending,
you'd come over, right? ♪
♪ You'd come over
and you'd stay the night ♪
♪ Would you love me
for the hell of it? ♪
♪ All our fears
would be irrelevant ♪
-Oh, oh, oh.
-♪ If the world was ending,
you'd come over, right? ♪
♪ The sky'd be falling
while I hold you tight ♪
♪ No, there wouldn't
be a reason why ♪
♪ We would even
have to say goodbye ♪
♪ If the world was ending,
you'd come over, right? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Heavy breathing ]
[ Chuckling ]
JoJo Siwa!
"The J Team" is out now
on Paramount Plus.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Ben Platt.
♪♪
-♪ But if the world was ending,
you'd come over, right? ♪
♪ You'd come over
and you'd stay the night ♪